comme l'avait promis manuel Vals le
ministre de l'Intérieur pour cette fin
d'année 2012 les chiffres des véhicules
incendiés ont été communiqués dans les
Yvelines la préfecture a recensé pour
cette soirée du réveillon du Nouvel An
28 voitures brûlées et 13 autres par
propagation soit un total de 41 cinq
personnes ont été interpellées pour fait
de violence le préfet a estimé dans un
communiqué de presse que la situation a
été globalement calme en ce qui concerne
la sécurité routière cette fois aucun
mort n'est à déplorer sur route du
département en la matière de nouvelles
mesures sont annoncées en ce début
d'année comme la mise en place des
nouveaux radars tronçons trois en tout
en Vallet de Chevreuse et en forêt de
Saint-Germain en
lait